(gentle music)
- Mazes are one of the
most fascinating things.
Almost everybody, soon as they can crawl,
are always wanting to
find out what's hidden,
what's out of sight.
(gentle music)
My name's Adrian Fisher, I
live in Dorset, in England,
and I create mazes and
labyrinths all over the world.
(adventurous music)
Well I spent the first few years
of my career in accountancy.
There came a moment when
I'd created a maze in my father's garden,
and then I started building
one, and two more and so on.
And then I suddenly realized
this was gonna be far more fulfilling
if I spent my life creating mazes.
This is the site of the place.
This is 40 meters in diameter
and the maze is going here.
Over the years I've created
mazes in some 40 countries,
and I guess I've built over 700
full-sized mazes in the landscape.
I think that maze design
is a very esoteric art.
You sketch out ideas and develop ideas
on paper from drawings.
But one of the exciting
things is a maze is a network.
Now, a maze is a special kind of network
where I decide there's
only one start point,
I decide where the finish is,
and I make sure that
every single bit of it
can be as confusing or as easy as I wish.
I'm trying to make it as
ingenious and tricky as possible,
but in the end I'm also an entertainer.
I like to leave clues
that help you solve it
and you feel so good about yourselves
when you have beaten the maze designer.
(adventurous music)
Like a good movie you get to
the end and you're still...
You don't want it to stop.
(adventurous music)
I'm appealing to some
basic instinct in us all
that want to be entertained and explore
and a maze is an ideal way of doing that.
It's purpose is totally to one side
of normal, sensible,
practical things in life,
but gives so much pleasure
to so many millions.
(adventurous music)